ah it's on me he's gotta kill day well
God hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica and also welcome back to the
wall of names yeah I finally got the
materials necessary to build the lockers
again and I've already been picked I've
packed yeah I have picked out four
comments from the comments section and
the first one is red Eichorn who said if
you beat the sea Emperor you win the
game and I'm not entirely sure that's
true
considering the sea Emperor isn't in the
game but the sea dragon leviathan is and
the sea dragon leviathan resides in the
inactive lava zone and then there's been
Gosper who said tip number two don't
ever ever forget that there are Reaper
leviathans and I don't know how I could
because I'm about to venture round the
back end of the rora and I'm pretty sure
when I go over there I'm gonna have a
whole bunch of leviathans in my face and
I don't have the batteries necessary to
be able to deviate the path around them
so I'm just hoping I'm gonna get lucky
and they don't spot me and gobble me up
but you know anything could happen here
around the Aurora then there's lemon
queen who said hey Marco sparkle you
haven't forgotten your children right
I'm sure you remember their names
obviously and yes I do it's Geoffrey
Billy Samwise and Marshall and no I
didn't look that up before the start of
the episode stop doubting me I know what
I'm doing and then there's ducks for
safe devil jokes for days who said I
eagerly await the return of bubble bud
which is what I'm gonna name my seamoth
because that was my favorite favorite
name besides obviously [ __ ] doc was a
good name but I'll rename Maya my big
old Submariner [ __ ] a duck instead of
[ __ ] the ocean I don't know I'll figure
it out Sam goes on anyway this is just
about groan it's only got eight percent
left but it's not quite there so what
I'm gonna do
what did I put this I didn't put
anything that luggage bag there's
nothing in there so what I got in here
is I got some copper so I actually do
have this stuff necessary to be able to
make more batteries I believe [ __ ]
[ __ ] a [ __ ] I need to go get acid
mushrooms Oh No
please tell me that sunrise and not
sunset because one of those is my
favorite things and one of those is the
absolute worst thing in the world
eventually I'll need to fire off [ __ ]
man I seem to be going through all God's
Sun is setting well this is gonna be a
dark episode good thing I'm gonna get
enough batteries to be able to navigate
the dark with my sea glider I don't know
if I'm gonna be able to do that well and
survive so I'm gonna make up some
batteries and eventually what I'll need
to do is I'll need to make these the
battery charger again because I can't
constantly keep making these batteries
over and over again it's a waste of
resources when I can recharge them but I
just don't have the capacity to do that
but now we're getting into the extremely
new territory in this game because
there's a lot of new stuff and there's a
lot of new setup to get new stuff I've
been told that there are new sections in
the Aurora I don't know where they are
if they're in the same hole in the wall
that'll get me there that's where I'm
gonna go first just because that's what
I'm familiar with but also I've been
told there's stuff around the back side
of the Aurora where it used to just be
empty ocean now I don't know what else
there could be in there and I'm just
gonna stuff everything in lemon queen
here even though that sounds really
weird but either way I'm gonna put away
what I don't need and I don't think I
need titanium on the way out there so I
I'm gonna put overflow and jokes for
days I don't need to maybe I do need the
fire extinguisher because if I go on the
Aurora I might actually need that so I'm
gonna swap batteries here oh no I'm
actually pretty good here okay so who
[ __ ] you man Jesus I think I scared him
more than I scared me but he still
scared me enough to fill my pants with
poop and pee little cut that out me
I'm already on the back side of the
Aurora I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] stop why
did you bite my butthole you [ __ ] you
butthole biting [ __ ] [ __ ] you
anyways that's not what I'm here we'll
need to see if I can get any rare
minerals out of this
nope just titanium okay so I guess
change of plans we're gonna go straight
around the backside of the Aurora ah
okay so hopefully I need that quartz
maybe that quartz we're gonna be okay
what are you doing here ah oh that was a
mistake all right we'd over into a place
I didn't want to dive into cuz I didn't
realize we were here just yet oh good a
Power Cell that's actually kind of nice
okay we some won't have to make those
I'll probably need that first-aid kit
because I'm gonna get written in the
[ __ ] punch
I got a Karen thanks for looking out for
me
ooh boy we got some rumblies down here
good thing when the engines exploded it
dumped all the Power Cells directly
below the engines oh god that doesn't
look safe well this looks like a dead
end okay
can't seem to maneuver around here ten
seconds of oxygen remaining I'm on it
Karen I'm going I'm surfacing reaching
whoa God where's the end of the show oh
god oh [ __ ] oh ha ha ha I survived I
don't know how that did how many people
were holding their own breasts expecting
me to drown again that ain't gonna
happen because I am super super smart oh
did this run out of batteries really
already well that's no good
alrighty then
okay I don't know where the [ __ ] I am
and I don't stop [ __ ] is that what is
that what am I looking at no not I mean
now what am I looking at what am i
hearing
oh why why is there new music here okay
whoa what's that I don't know okay
what the [ __ ] ah why did I have to come
here at night alrighty then oxygen
really I need that I need that I need
that okay going up Jesus it said
something about extending the debris
field and I'm guessing this is this must
be like all the new like uh Jesus there
it is
this must be like all the new the new
new debris I guess but I still think I'm
around the engines
it's jeez oh I don't like this hello
I don't like the new music going on
there am I still over the engines oh my
god I am holy [ __ ] this thing as wide as
[ __ ] I do not remember this [ __ ] the
ship the [ __ ] ship being this wide like
a holy crap oh my god that is nuts okay
we only just now cleared the back end of
the ship and it's only just now becoming
day which is awfully convenient thanks
for doing that by the way all right so
who okay that's not very comforting to
know that as soon as I dive down this
goddamn sea dragon Leviathan what is
that oh that's Linda I thought I thought
that was the outline of a goddamn fish
ooh that's no good you just stay down
there in the deep I'll stay here in the
shallows we won't talk to each other and
meet each other do anything to each
other ever all right well that was a
terrifying adventure that I didn't want
to go on that absolutely did not intend
to go to and around and where the [ __ ]
am I that's a weird landmass that I've
never seen before
oh hey okay you're not too threatening
okay so what's weird is what why I'm so
freaked out by this is this is all
completely new to me like this obviously
has not been here none of this is
accounted for I have no idea where I'm
going and we're starting to really get
into the new territory here because all
this land mass was not here before that
is 100% definite and I definitely don't
even remember seeing the aurora on this
kind of scale here hello hello bird
things whatever flying creatures you are
I'm pretty sure this is just an
outcropping that the aurora is stuck on
to but I just need to I just need to
explore it to be able to see if there's
anything important here because
otherwise I do believe it's just some
sort of thing
um I'm not seeing anything on the
horizon - maybe something over there why
is it so rumbly zero or just constantly
sinking more and more doesn't seem good
I'm just gonna get this quartz while I
can I don't think there's any other
place that I can go to up there so I'm
just gonna have to go on my own down
here whoop okay and hopefully avoid some
deathly encounters I probably should
have gotten some more food with me
because I might have a bit of an issue
once it comes to that is it looks like
I'm about to make a lap of the entire
Aurora cuz I'm getting towards the front
here and I don't know if there's
anything in the drop-off I don't have my
seamoth which is what I really need to
be able to explore more of this area but
I don't have it yet I am getting to the
front of the Aurora though so I'm just
gonna you know I just kind of want to
make an accounting of the the full area
oh god that's a drop-off ah ah hey being
naked in the ocean okay
well that looks a lot more magnanimous
than it did before I'm not fooling
myself is that bigger is that bigger
than it was or am I just seeing it from
a different perspective than I have in
the past because that looks goddamned
huge I mean the aurora is so
unbelievably big like the aurora is just
[ __ ] duckin huge how many people died on
this ship how many people died not only
in the initial explosion oh [ __ ] but
afterwards just how many there had to be
tens of thousands of people on a ship
this size I believe this was a colony
ship intended to colonize a planet have
everything that it needed to start a
completely independently functioning
colony and I think I may have found
something
here I don't know just look look
colorful so I was assuming maybe there
was some technology man that's got to be
bigger there's got to be bigger this is
so huge it's so huge oh my god but even
if it is it doesn't matter because I'm
gonna go inside it next sir way in
through there maybe maybe not
seems to be a way up I'm just gonna test
it out because I don't know no harm in
looking
no harm in looking from this end if
anything I can just go in the ship
backwards from this at it from this area
hopefully tread oak ship structural
integrity is low exploration not advised
well too bad I'm gonna explore anyway
batteries
filtered water good need to move watch
our buddies I got a knife and I'm not
afraid to use it
goddamn oh this is flipping nuts okay
in we go oh my god there's so many
things thank you I guess
whoa so many Power Cells can I get some
like can I get some like food I'm I
might run low on food before I'll [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] hell is that fire [ __ ]
I just fallen debris the cheese okay I
need to take a first-aid kit and get
some water in me
I've got oodles and oodles and oodles of
Power Cells which is really quite useful
whew
well that was close ah I'm falling I'm
falling I'm falling we were falling okay
um so I couldn't make my way back in it
seemed to be a dead end anyway so I'm
gonna try to find the other way in that
I normally know about and hopefully
that's gonna mean that I can get some
more supply crates on the way but the
good news is if there is good news to
take out of this is this if there is
good news ooh what is this ooh hey
that's handy okay cool oh jeez
the Cyclops pieces they're over here
neato burrito Oh neato I'm on it I'm on
a Karen thank you husky okay so if I get
my bearings right my base should be over
here the biomass and ah ah ah ah it's on
me
he's got a guild aid Oh God oh no yeah
he'll never get me in here Oh God
Oh God oh god don't get stuck did it
stop did it stop was it never after me
in the first place oh what's that glowy
bit there was something the-the-the
Karen was trying to tell me in text but
I didn't see it because I was screaming
this is a little busy running for my
goddamn life it said something about
pieces of the Aurora and something about
the plants or are dominant in this area
I'm not 100% sure I don't know man I
don't know at least I got Power Cells
for days and extra batteries to go with
it so I should be good on Power Cells
for like the rest of my life even though
I didn't get a chance to scan any more
for the Cyclops but that's not really
why I'm here jeez that was not fun it
seems like the hole-in-the-wall entrance
that they had previously might not be
here anymore
not under percent sure about that okay
I'm gonna put my take these out of there
you're gonna be the power uh jokes for
days is gonna be power for days so I'm
just gonna put the used batteries in
there and keep the unused ones all right
see don't do do and do okay so we got
our total of eight trees getting ready
which should provide me more than enough
food when I come in here this food won't
stay if I want food to take on the road
I either need to find rations or figure
out a way to make rations if there's an
available recipe on the ship but I don't
know if that's gonna happen so okay so
my next step is I just got to find a way
into the Aurora and I'm not gonna waste
your time I'm just gonna go for it and
when I come back hopefully I'll have
found my way in I just have a funny
feeling it might have been on the other
side and I was in such a panic that I
did not see it because it's very
obviously not in the same place that it
once was like maybe maybe if I use my
first aid or fire extinguisher here
I mean hey that works that weirdly
enough that works whoo [ __ ] Catherine's
weirded it's actually putting out these
fires ooh hello whoo yay oh cool
yes I knew there had to be a way oh
that's so cool there was like a sort of
hidden walkway
I mean hidden I can't see [ __ ] but I
found it eventually I knew there had to
be something here oh cool and they gave
you first aid kits just in case you
needed it because I got burnt by fire
this is where I need to do oh and
there's an extra fire extinguisher oh
cool
Oh is there anything else here oh it's
so cool oh it's so cool I love that love
that okay there's nothing else here
alright so now I knew there had to be
another way in that's so cool and I'm
gonna take this first a kid just because
you know I may get hurt in there who
knows honestly huff whoosh alright so I
got that but hang on I'm out on this one
drop that one
put that one whoopsies one whoosh all
right firefighter mark millar coming in
a foosh okay that way to the airlocks
well all of the airlocks have exploded
into space so that's no nice we're
actually in a ship ship oh my god well
hello whoa cool is this what I needed it
okay systems are running on local
reserve matter
I need to find another piece of that
that's the propulsion cannon which
should be oh I get it
okay so there's okay so I heard about
this that you needed the propulsion
cannon to be able to move through here
and now it's making sense because there
are physical obstacles blocking my way
and I'm willing to bet that I can't just
jump over them can I can I use my sweet
hopping skills nope maybe a little bit
of hippity hop over here nope alright so
I'm gonna play that the right way on I'm
gonna find the other piece of the
propulsion cannon and then I'm gonna be
able to move those but I should should
be able to go over here and hopefully
something else that I can get that I
might need this is where I would need
the fire extinguisher you stop burning
oh what's it stop please tell me there's
some food in here just a little bit of
leftover food would be nice alright
prawn suit nice pick up prawn suit
poster why do I need that can I put that
in my base to make it feel a little more
like home
that'd be nice this I can scale I can
put a trash can in my place oh that's
lovely unless there's something in this
trashcan that I absolutely need maybe
trash cans nope just got a blueprint for
trash cans new blueprint acquired okay
Altera launches the Aurora
new encyclopedia stuff okay but I
haven't found the other piece of the
propulsion kick over that way is there
something here that I'm missing is there
anything here that I'm missing it's
gotta be here I'm risking starvation I
could probably find a way to jump over
these boxes though I bet I could oh
hello oh no this will be easy her ah
well that didn't work or hang on try
that again only got nine percent food
left which means starvation is imminent
if I go over here burn myself a bit and
just drop down wolf No
No No oh yeah I made it okay good all
right so I got that I need to brush up
real quick and then we're going we're
running out of food we're running out of
oh god no that locked that locked I
don't know the code was it him wait was
it in one of the logs that I got hang on
uh damage pattern does not match any no
an offensive technology that's because
it was all liquid in shi'ite
codes yes yay okay ah 14:54 okay Baba
Duvall read the rest of that 14:54 yeah
open please give me food Oh God
hello holy [ __ ] what what this is
awesome hello I'll take that you whoa
hey whoa oh my god I'm gonna starve to
death but at least I'm gonna have a lot
of plans for when I get back and
resurrect in my own base all is so cool
yay a nutrient block yes yes yes oh my
god oh that was so I'm saving now oh
that was so perfectly time to thank you
I should have scanned it [ __ ] whoa hey
that's handy alrighty then
I got that now I got 1/3 a piece of
everything in the Cyclops well now that
I have more time to actually explore
this thing I should be able to take a
closer look at every oh that's so cool
oh that is so cool can I scan that okay
I can't scan the nutrient block I don't
know why I thought I could I don't know
why I thought I'd try but hey first time
for everything why not give it a gander
oh that's so cool oh this is awesome
yes more nutrient blocks yes please Oh
Ben ah that was a gamble that paid off
in dividends
because my god usually whenever I take a
stupid bet like that it never ever ever
pans out for me okay so nothing other up
here I got to avoid all the droppy bits
of fire everywhere okay so uh Geronimo I
suppose okay yeah
can I have you thank you anything else
in there no how another nutrient block
whoa
well this looks scary but why not see
mouth babe
we were working at the seamoth pattern
yes yeah I'm wondering why there aren't
more dead bodies floating everywhere
unless they've already all been eaten by
the local fish life like that one [ __ ]
you yeah [ __ ] that parasitic piece of
[ __ ]
yeah I just walked off [ __ ] [ __ ] can
you can you not can you not can you can
you can you not thank you shut up [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you did I get you I'm gonna
getcha yeah [ __ ] off okay you know what
I'm just getting out of here because
[ __ ] those things okay ah drive room I
don't know if I need to go the drive
room I was looking for the drive core
shielding sustained moderate internal
damage during collision do not attempt
repair without appropriate
qualifications oh yeah this is where I
would stop all the radiation leakage
damn it I'm almost out of fire juice
okay but this is good because this is
where you would have come in if they
still had the other thing available
right now science our efficiency module
that's handy I do not have a repair tool
yet but this is good to know I wonder if
there's still like any sort of uh
scannable pieces here so once I get a
repair tool I will come back to this I
do not have time for that now jump over
the fire go to the seamoth Bay find what
I need find my seemeth Bay
Oh No Oh No ah [ __ ] I need a laser
cutter [ __ ] where the [ __ ] do I get that
damn it so many things here that I don't
have oh no I can't go to the seamoth Bay
oh no I need the repair tool can I even
make that I don't even know if I can
make that hang on let's get out of a
dangerous infested area ah [ __ ] off ya
piece of [ __ ]
goddamnit I guess it go back to the
drive room huh okay alright so do I know
how to make that is the big question I
can make a repair tool and I can make a
laser cutter so what I need to do is I
need to go make those things and then
come back here but I know how to come
back here so that means that [ __ ]
stop with the fire Jesus ok so that
means that when I get back here unless
it was a way to get out here but I don't
think there is holy [ __ ]
ok so when I come back here I will get
the laser cutter and the the the not the
not so laser cutter ok so I'm not seeing
anything else here just yet so I'm
assuming I'm done for now and I will
come back when I have everything that I
need which I don't have right now and
I'm assuming that it wanted me to find
the propulsion cannon before it was
gonna allow me to just waltz on out of
here but hey they should have made it a
bit more blocked up if that's what they
really wanted so anyway I'm all out of
time for this episode but I got a lot on
my list to do for the next one so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down the
comments below and I might just put you
on a locker if you do and thanks again
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]